[Music]
just at the point where we thought we
won it turns out we've always planned
this to be a trilogy it only gets bigger
from him just recently
a undead
anti-life virus has taken the entire
earth and over five years we've lost so
many superheroes they come together and
deceased dead planet to find a cure to
find a vaccine and now
we get to the next point you're going to
see that unliving dark side infected all
the new gods and now we have a war
against the undead gods across the
cosmos yeah the undead gods thing is is
no that was new to me i love it brainiac
will be a player we will probably see
the likes of sinestro we'll see
green lanterns we'll see lobo we'll see
new gods guy gardner of course is a
character that i always enjoy riding so
he gets
probably some of my favorite lines of
issue 2 there's going to be acetate
wrapped covers of course we've got
another matina faces of death cover and
we have some fantastic dan moore of
variant covers homages to something that
we can't speak of but i think fans will
be very excited just like with every
other issue of deceased we have a big
shock basically at the end of every
issue so every page i draw i'm going oh
wow okay that's happening hey as always
don't get attached to anyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you